how would you categorize race relations
between black and white people in the
United States today from a media
standpoint
division welcome back for part two of
the newest series black and white on the
gray issues last time we took to the
streets to see if relations between
black and white Americans were actually
as bad as Legacy Media would have you
believe and what do you know the
narrative couldn't be further from the
truth turns out you can actually find
some common ground and have great
dialogues when you actually start
talking with people
that being said I'd be lying if I said
it was entirely smooth sailing if you
talk to enough people you will
eventually find an outlier and this was
an outlier which took place in our final
interview of the day now without
spoiling too much see if you can tell
how this particular conversation went
differently are the reason still be SL
if it was for you baby all right just
for a second it may be that I'm a little
oldfashioned that seems a little wild to
me but let me know in the comments below
what do you think does woman just offer
Fair assessment or pure unadulterated
Insanity let me ask you where how where
would you put or how would you
categorize race relations between black
and white people in the United States
today I think from a media standpoint
div division right um I think that's
that's where we are I think that there
is Division I do I think um there's
definitely some microaggressions and
things like that that are apparent but
on my everyday interacting
um I think
it's I think it's an array of things I
think there's some positivity there's
some there's some growth opportunities I
think I have um within my circle there's
it's diverse yeah um and I love that
it's diverse but I also think um that
we're not having those conversations
within my diverse community so when you
say diverse do you mean you mean
racially do you mean ideologically
politically um politically and racially
okay yeah so you have white black
Republican Democrat and all in your
circle of friends yes I have pretty much
everything what would you say um has uh
kind of helped you I think I think
learning from different people helps you
grow what would you say has helped you
grow more having people of different
races in your circle of friends are
people of different ideologies people
from different walks of life I think
walks of life yeah
I think you learn more I think because I
can meet another African-American person
who's had a different upbringing than I
do and and I'm learning what their
struggle looks like versus my struggle
cuz it's very different um I think it's
really truly about being open yeah open
to listening open to learning um and
having the conversations so you're
saying that in your day-to-day your
experiences have been good probably
because of your circle of friends
compared to the media sounds like you're
saying there is some division out there
but not so much in your circle of
friends not within my circle of friends
because I choose them right right so
this is my choice it's my choice to have
people in my circle that I don't have to
to fight with all the time that we are
open and we learn from one another but I
take a look at where we are in their
schools they go to private schools okay
so um there's complete division um with
um race racial divide um seeing our
black boys in the private school Arena
um getting trouble where the white boys
don't get in trouble for the same
offense I see that every day why don't
you just take them out of private
schools um because at the end of the day
it's a better education is it yeah okay
it is cuz that's got to be tough then if
you have to choose like what kind of
things do they get into trouble for that
white kids wouldn't like what do you um
a fist fight I brought it up last year
if you see two black kids in a fist
fight they'll probably get suspended you
see two white kids in a fist fight which
rarely happens in private school then
it's a pat on the back it's very r i
don't I can't tell if you're joking or
if you're serious is it rare like white
kids get into a fight in a private
school or are you saying they get in
just as many fights no fight in general
at private school is very rare okay in
general whether white or black whether
whatever race it is okay right yeah I
was raised in Canada where um we had a
zero tolerance policy so it didn't
matter if you defended yourself uh or
you started the fight you were all
suspended which I think is morally
reprehensible I think it's I think I was
suspended because I got punched in the
face well that's not good no no because
you were defending yourself yeah I
didn't well I didn't really I mostly
just turtled oh okay well I'm going to
need you to defend next time I learned
that later on but see at that point I
was a little is what I was I
didn't know I was afraid the kid was 2
years older than me 14 that's good 14 to
16 it's a huge difference you're not
going to do anything in just maturity
body your just all the whole thing yeah
the whole thing the whole thing oh it
was a terrible experience but I think
it's a good example we weren't teaching
kids that hey not all violence is
equivalent like if someone attacks you
you're saying this as a mom you would
probably want your kids to defend
themselves to defend yeah of course I
would yeah yeah I mean I think that's
that's why it says um there's a legal
defense for defending yourself no
absolutely right um you mentioned
microaggressions so you're the first
person today who's mentioned that mhm uh
what do you mean by that
microaggressions meaning they say little
things um they meaning um non people of
color we'll say little things not
realizing that it's a microaggression
not realizing that um it's hurtful that
um it's racism cuz it's so micro so like
what would be an example of that my hair
oh my God can I touch your hair oh my
God Is that real um things of that
nature are um we didn't do that it's
just kartin you want to give me some
microaggressions uh
like not real you you speak
so you're speak so well even though I'm
using English ume I'm going to be
speaking using a oracular or bonics
whatever you want to say it put it as
but yeah it's just things like that
they're little things I remember in six
grade somebody said my hair looked like
spaghetti hair because I
had twist in I don't know what y'll look
it up look up twist my I have like BR
twist in they say the hair look like
burnt spaghetti and that's a
microaggression right you don't realize
it but it is hurtful the long run it
makes you feel othered and that's not
okay when I was in high school I had uh
my hair was I had a horrible haircut and
it was cut uh very short in the sides
and T and uh I was told that I looked
like a Patrick Dempsey nice so it
wasn't so much a microaggression as a
that's just aggression that's just
aggression aggression but my point is it
happens that happens to to everybody my
question is I think maybe it comes down
to is that necessarily racist or if we
just view it through the lens of maybe
this is something I'm uncomfortable with
but they're not they're not meaning it
to be racist right racism would have to
come with intent um racism does not have
does not have to be intentional racism
can be subtle for sure it could be
subtle there's something called
internalized racism because of how
Society um just shows things off right a
lot of women a lot of girls it's look at
Disney apprentices there's only one
black Disney princess and that's not
crazy but little girls look at their
little princesses right and they look at
all this array of like plenty of white
women right and they aspire to be that a
lot of the times and I feel like little
things like that you're internalizing
racism even though it's not blatant
racism I think everyone thinks that
racism is this like thing that people go
out and hurt people with but a lot of
the times just like the way you think
you think white bodies on white people
first and don't necessarily got people
color in your life right it's more so a
mindset than blatant like hurting people
you know what I mean what would be I
guess sorry do you are you comfortable
talking with your mom or I'm sure okay
here do you mind getting into it so I
don't cuz right now the camera's going
to be going back and forth like it's
going to be going back and forth like a
Wes Anderson film so you see we're not
trying to to send back what was your
name by the way she so amazing carington
this is what she does she's so amazing
Eddie um could you give me some examples
there in maybe more examples of
internalized racism because let me tell
you where white people are nervous okay
okay this love to hear that yeah so in
other words if you're talking about
white people um being racist right
toward you and that's a legitimate
concern of course in some places you're
going to have individual RAC racists uh
it's a different conversation from
systemic racism right or internalized
racism but we all acknowledge that I
will tell you this the reason that a lot
of white people don't have these kinds
of conversations like this is because
they're afraid of being accused of being
no they're afraid of being accused of
being racist yeah white fragility well
see that's that is an attack to just say
white fragility what if someone for
example we just interviewed every single
black man who we interviewed today every
single one said yeah the black lives
matter thing got out of hand all lives
matter everyone's lives matter and I
don't think that was good for either
Community every single black man that we
interviewed today and if I were to say
that same thing right because I don't
think the problem is just race and I
think we do have a failed justice system
by the way I think you'll miss it if you
think it's just race well we can't
classify that as white white fragility
or a microaggression so let me I
disagree with every white man every
black man you spoke with today but go
ahead but they're entitled to their
opinion it surprised me that they said
so white fragility means that we're on I
think we're on the same page you're just
defining is different why fragility
means when black people are afraid to
confront the fact that they might have
racism or might have racist thoughts
that's right fragility so what if they
don't they don't literally almost
everybody in America does because of the
way America works even black people have
racist thoughts towards black people
right so it's kind of hard to get out of
there unless you're like not from
America and even then it's pretty
difficult um so literally everyone has
some form of racist thoughts but white
people it's just easier because they're
not black or they're not a person of
color they don't have the system around
them necessarily to confront that
because they don't have to right so it
takes more work on their part right and
there's nothing really necessarily well
that's it's not great but there's
nothing wrong with working more harder
to get to a certain point you know what
I mean okay so so I just want to be
clear that I understand this as a you
know white guy obviously um is uh and I
I get it look we're coming from
different perspectives you're defining
something that you just would require
more work right it would be a form of
racism that they may not known that
frankly is something that they were born
with white white fragility um through no
fault of their own yeah what you just
outlined is is is racism right mhm I
mean no you saying white fragility
that's a that would be R racist toward
like saying yeah you you are blamed for
something that you were born with you
have white fragility just racism no
literally everybody has their own form
of racial fragility you know that right
so there's so there is black fragility
is a term that's taught two latino
fragility I mean everyone can be racist
towards certain people and when black
people are called out for certain things
in the black community um that are not
necessarily great for the black
community they get sometimes they'll get
defensive especially if it's not
somebody coming from the black community
cuz one that could be seen as like
perceived hate because you never know
who you're talking to um and also just
because like life fragility is a
complicated subject because a lot of
people feel it you know what I mean and
it does hurt people uh their emotions so
it's really hard to just kind of break
that down and I feel like that's really
the issue is people are not willing to
break that down being having refug is
not a good thing but most white people
have it so they have to work through it
you know what I mean I think it's just
because Society puts this on other
people it's not necessarily like white
people's fault it's society's fault for
putting that on on white people and
that's a lot of thing with like racism
Society puts things on black people
right but I feel like I think white
people put it on themselves I don't I
think white people are Society I think
it's one and the same so I think let me
explain this our society is based off of
white supremacy from a historical
standpoint right from the Tulsa Massacre
to slavery to to literally like all our
presidents except for one being black
from the long per history period of time
right our society is based on the ideal
of whiteness
from the nuclear household one two
parent households things like that and
black people can have two parent
households but that's not how our
community has ever been based even from
Africa we we have been based on a
village style of living and working
together we takes a whole village to
raise a child and by people truly embody
that while white people tend to have
more of a nuclear family one parent I
mean two parents and a few children and
they work together right there's nothing
Surly wrong with the nuclear family but
it does it is like an embodiment of the
American dream and whiteness right so
because society's built on all this
whiteness and all of these standpoints
that are made for white people they're
just more used to that right and they're
not really used to thinking outside the
box and think about people of color and
that's what I'm talking about and when
they're confronted that the fact that
they don't think about people of color
you get wet fragility cuz they're scared
and they didn't want to realize that
they let me let me rephrase this they
didn't realize that they weren't
thinking about people color or they were
in the back of their mind and they get
scared right so I I hear you I hear you
but I disagree with you because I think
right now and at this very moment you
saying that's racist is privilege honey
that's nothing but
privilege to be able to be able to say
that I shouldn't be able to say that I
mean we no to be able to say it and to
live in that I think it's white making
the right argument the the definition of
racism is power behind discrimination
you can discriminate against white
people anyone can but you can't
necessarily be racist towards white
people racism comes from discrimination
plus um a place in society where you get
to have power right that is the clinical
not clinical if you look on Google
that's not necessarily what you're going
to get because Google dumbs things down
right but if you look at like we agree
there yeah right so if you look at like
more like racial context if you look
like uh Belle oh my God I forgot name
Bell Hooks and so many different um
racial Scholars that's the definition
that is greatly agreed on in the
academic space so racism is
discrimination plus power essentially so
white people have more power then most
people of color all people of color in
the United States while some people of
color don't have as much power so
punching up it's not the same as
punching down anybody can discriminate
against anybody that's just a fact but
racism is based on a system of
power now I don't know if this would be
white would you be open to the idea that
some of those things maybe are incorrect
and someone may be white and say hey
you're wrong about this historically and
that not be called White PR I mean if
you get the facts I can't even you know
like there's if you have like facts and
you have proof to like back it there's
no issues with that what I'm more
talking like what I'm talking about the
nuclear family that's a big one I don't
know if you know this but there were far
more in in the United States it's a far
lower divorce rate for a very long
period of time at the same time that
black households had higher literacy
rates you why there's a lower divorce
rate there was a lower divorce rate for
a very long time cuz women had to cuz
they had own credit cards they couldn't
get divorced they couldn't live without
a man that's literally the reason why
the divorce rate was so low I'm talking
about before this by the way
historically talking about from the
Inception of the country before the seet
movement so this would be the same thing
that white women and black women would
face the issues you're talking about so
those same groups black families were
very strong had low divorce rates had
large households and a big part of it
was because of the faith basis back then
and it was a again the community right
the church would also encourage strong
households I notice Eddie have you have
a wedding are you so are you married yes
yeah my dad okay now let me ask you why
why what why why are you send your kids
to private school which is very
commendable right you to care about your
kids you're married if I didn't I would
still care sure I'm financially able
right if she wasn't what do you think
that the reason you choose to be married
and have a nuclear household did you
make that decision because it was what
you thought was best or do you think
that's because of white supremacy white
fragility well there's things that are
implicit and also like for my mom it's
just because she loaded my dad our
household's not that nucular because we
have so many people that support us
outside of our house like it's not just
all Mom and Dad I want to go to my uncle
he take care of me you know what I mean
it's not really that nuclear my husband
is fine yeah and I love him he's my man
and that's why that's that's a wonderful
thing that's it yeah so it's not a
byproduct of that one white supremacy
white supremacy soci a lot of live in a
nuclear household anyway at our home so
we can't it's a village we can't so we
can't really apply that to us anyways
yeah you can do you know how many do you
know how many kids white or black go to
private school if they don't have a mom
and dad in the house oh statistically
none whether you're white or black it's
very
who are still there and I think that's
by way it's a huge blessing I think what
you just said about your husband I would
love to hear everyone say about the
husband and their wife yeah she loves
him very much yeah that's one thing
actually when we talk about I think that
uh a lot of white women probably could
learn from is there's a lot of loyalty
in the black community a sense of
community that often white people do not
have um and you'll see it with men and
women you'll see it with them leaving
pretty quickly uh I think that's a
beautiful thing but I think that's a
huge privilege for everybody regardless
of race but his historically if someone
and I don't even want to get into
exactly where I would disagree
historically as far as you know Africa
the idea of the nuclear family being
white supremacy or Disney Princesses but
my question is where can a white person
because we've had conversations all that
where can a white person disagree and
say
yeah that's not racism or you know what
I don't I don't agree with the idea of
white fragility and them not be a racist
okay cuz you just cuz I was just told
that that is privileged to even say I
disagree with your opinion no no that's
not necessar we saying you kind of
lowkey said that anyways but what I'm
saying is you have if you have the facts
um talking to oh oh okay okay I tell me
when hope you have the back you have the
backing there's no issue with debating
something but you need to understand
what the core is so somebody said I
don't think white fragility is exists
because XYZ reasons and someone comes
back with no and they're still very like
um hard-headed about it or they don't
see the reasons or they don't really
look into those facts that's where the
issue lies if there's an actual
discussion I don't really care if you
think refil is real or not because
eventually you are going to come to an
opinion that is not necessarily based on
how you feel but on facts and then from
there you can do whatever you want I
don't necessarily care about like what
people so like if someone were to go
through example just to kind of use your
timeline and if someone who was raised
in Canada right not the United States
someone use your timeline say actually
you know according to um Professor West
you know black men black activists uh
well over 95% of slaves in Africa were
sold into slavery by slave Traders
including largely black African slave
traders of course it's wrong and this
was the first country to fight the
bloodiest revolution in history in order
to free the slaves because they
recognized that it was ungodly based on
the Dayo Christian principles and we
sign the Emancipation Proclamation we
were not uniquely responsible for
starting slavery we were uniquely
responsible for ending it in the modern
world there are more slave today than
ever in recorded history on earth right
now2
million 42 million and someone says so
since there are more slaves on Earth
today largely in the Middle East in
Africa and in Asia that it would imply
that those countries are probably more
systemically racist than the least
systemically racist country in the world
of the United States some were to walk
through that line of History through it
very incorrectly without understanding
the basis and the foundation of African
can't say people ended racism because
black people fought to end racism so
white people are the reason sles if it
was for you baby your for white people
we would still be enslaved I believe
that I believe how much you from
Washington from Jefferson from Lincoln
after he was raping all the SL slave
women and and making babies them
inacurate that is very true we're
talking about that's very true Jefferson
they fre their slaves upon their death
because it was illegal ATT very true he
raped slaves and he has
children children raped Sally Hamilton's
wife had plenty of slaves so let's not
even they all had slaves because they
from the old country where they were and
raped them and had children
jeers has a line of children okay so do
you believe you believe that if it were
up to all white people meaning the north
that people then we would still be
enslaved okay that's not a good take
anyways I love you but no I that and
that's my my belief I think so what was
the start what the ofers existed you
know but what I am saying is that cuz
quers exist you can't blame all you know
I don't want to blame all but I do think
that because all white people there's
Quakers and people that is just like
that saying a lot of white people in the
past did not want a change in slavery
that mean like very much that's what I'm
saying not all white people today I'm
saying from that I'm
saying there's some people that didn't
right there's a lot white people who did
there's a lot people I'm all there's
some people who didn't but what I'm
saying is the reason that we got out of
slavery because of War can I say
something though without for both of you
because you both obviously are even
though she's 17 she can run circles
around you every day y'all are really
good at this just's waiting for it yeah
she's really good I still feel like
we're not going to get anywhere with
this conversation right cuz he started
off with the idea that it must be based
on racism we gr we're not growing in
this conversation at all and you can't
and you're defending no no and she's
defending nobody is moving forward
wouldn't it be incumbent in other words
we're talking about defending and this
is why I say we've had a lot of
conversations today this is why we're
down here right the first person to say
white fragility is something that can't
be
disproven is the conversation where it
cannot be productive because it starts
from a racist premise if I were to come
in and say hey you know what not enough
black people and white people are
talking about these issues and that's
because black people are incredibly
fragile that probably wouldn't be a
productive conversation right I think I
think I think I'm intelligent enough to
have that conversation I you can
definitely say that but he are fragile
about student things I think there's
something wrong with saying Tru it
there's truth to that I think every race
is as fragile as certain things within
that race I don't think that's
a
no you can say black people are fragile
about this certain I feel black people
are fragile you could say that and then
we can then educate you on why yes right
when I talked to you about ref fragility
every time you come up with like this is
racist this is racist this is racist
almost every single time and I talk is
and I disagree with you on that because
racism is power press oppression right I
mean Power Plus discrimination right and
you can't be have right fragility
because there's
no black people can't be ril is not
racist because it has no
um Power behind it right so or it has
mean there has power behind it towards
white people that's why it is like white
people having refil is racist does that
mean because that means they are like
they have a
racial believe black people have no
power behind them in the United States
um I think every race has power behind I
mean there's power in numbers but I
don't think our power is equal to the
white man oh exactly so here here's my
question for you because I'm I'm going
take I think it depends on the person as
whatever I don't I think depend
right so we're talking about industrial
system and things like that and racial
profiling and how people think things
how people categorizing stereotypes and
The Jezebel and the sapphire and all I
think think that's the word I think I
messed up the word on that maybe I
didn't and The Jezebel and the Mam and
all of those things and how black women
in healthare systems especially and
things like that you're just throwing
out words Jezebel can apply to white
people too what are you you're talking
about the idea especially inal shows
especially mental Souls it applies to
black women that stereotype is placed
more on black women it can apply to
white people but it's not as of we're
just across from restaurant the
vegan I mean it's something that goes
across the board my point is as a racial
issue slan is by black anyway what we're
saying there there are plenty of
a lot of people like
them hisorical it's biblical but also
historically has been used against black
people in Minal shows a lot too so it
has Jezebel has a slightly more racial
qued tone than the word does you
feel what I mean any of those problems
that you identif that because there's
one thing we've talked about today any
any of those problems that you just
identified for example you talk about
the prison industrial complex you talk
about school talk about government yeah
are any of those problems not racially
based so prent industrial system
definitely what was the next one public
education ucation um because of yeah
because of like where Living Spaces are
and because of like uh like systems and
slums and redlining and all the things
that's based on um antiblackness and
also based also on um class and class
Disney in there yeah uh well yeah Disney
has racism TI the Beanie Baby company
yeah um anyways uh I lost I lost a ton
of money on those I'm really waiting for
them to go value do you realize that Ty
the Beanie Baby company right now owns
the license for all the Disney SE
princesses but he refuses to make one
Disney princess and that happens to be
Tiana and he refuses to make that one
yeah so I'm just saying it lies within
so many different like just like think
about like who I I I got to tell you
yeah there's nothing to say about that
that's just horrible yeah I don't know
that that that's even true or that it's
because of her
race prin the Frog was one of most
successful mod disne true because his
director had a black mermaid that comes
from okay can I can I speak she was the
director of marketing director of
marketing it's very true I worked for
the company for five years so instead of
saying I don't know that's true I would
love for you to say oh my God that must
be hurtful this is where the Divide is
you automatically went to you
automatically let me speak you
automatically went for it back up a
little bit you automatically went for
the ne I don't know if that's true I
don't I don't know I don't know instead
of saying wow could that be true if so
that must don't know it's true and that
I don't I'm not going to ATT tell I'm
telling you what the tone is that you
just you been wrong about so much that I
don't trust what you're telling me you
just said that there weren't white
people freeing the slaves it was only
because of black people I didn't say
that raped his his woman not accurate so
I'll take how do you know he didn't rape
his woman there's a guy named David
Barton he has a bunch of artifacts were
you so were you Mama this mama ARG can I
answer your question can can I speak
then let's both say no then let's both
say no we both don't know this is I I
think we're kind of identifying a
primary issue it's not black white it's
male female I think that's the issue
that we're running into here no it is
black and white it's very black and
white I think that the interrupting and
the aggression and the implication that
someone needs to back up when I have not
taken any closer steps towards you I
don't care but if uncomfortable not and
we've been able to have productive
conversations with black men across the
board and by the way most women but
there does seem to be a divide in
interrupting and being abrasive and
certainly being more aggressive so mama
mama please wait a minute I didn't start
out that way make it we're going to make
itse let me say this you understand like
we're in a trap right you're making this
it is a trap let me say this it didn't
start out that way mhm you made me feel
that way I don't
care okay good
about the facts I wasn't to make you
feel that way end of the conversation
that's fine you just shown your true
colors I don't care that you feel that
way if you're wrong and that was you
were trap and you guys and this is every
single conversation today has been
productive we found more in common than
less every single one yeah with the
exception of this and this is the only
one where I was told I couldn't have an
opinion because of white fragility and I
just you have an opinion I S I said
personally that you could have an
opinion right I said that multiple times
as long as you come with facts and like
proof right cuz okay here we haven't
addressed any of them we have especially
with the same thing I said from my
sources and from my facts we have a
difference of facts and opinions so we
should have dropped that totally
completely and on to something else like
maybe the prison industrial system or
maybe something else that has more basis
but you just kind of handed on the fact
of one thing and you didn't really
address this is not like a great
conversation to have right and from my
mom she's not she's not like uh I'm
trained in debate so I know how to not
see certain debates you're making and I
know how to move around them or know how
to deal with them she does not so she'll
fall into that trap a little bit more
easily um of how what trap have I laid
I'm really not trying to lay trap you're
not a trap but you're being difficult to
talk to and understand and there's a a
lack of empathy on both sides and I feel
like that's the main issue is there's a
lack of empathy on both sides and we're
not really reading each other or hearing
each other and that's where the main
issue is and Mom she's pretty strong
will she's pretty stronge headed and
when she comes to debate she comes to
win I come from a different perspective
true so my my goal was this my goal was
this for us to hear each other and
within this
conversation I didn't feel that it
changed you just told me I don't care
you just said there's no facts you just
told me
everything negative instead of listening
in hearing and I thought this
conversation would have been completely
different
new you'll be able to see the behavior
that you have exhibited here and not
myself and you can watch it you can
rewind it that's what you think of black
women mom
you're making a a lot of statements
right now that are not helping this
conversation and making you look worse
is it possible that I think that maybe
you've been inite that maybe you've been
inaccurate in some of your assumptions
yourself people have been imp and not
because you're black we've both been
impolite and not because you're black so
why does it have anything to do with
your race if I just think you've been
aggressive I think so here's the thing
here here's what I want you to hear
whenever a a woman or a black
woman asserts herself or says this is
pleas do it it's so tired to do that
it's so tired to the conversation is now
over have a wonderful day because the
way you're treating me cuz you you're
when you say every time a black woman
asserts herself no no woman that's not
true that's not true that's not true
that's not what's happening a lot of
times often there's a thing called temp
policing I'm sure you know about it
right um and that happens a lot often to
people in these have that have these
conversations then people get aggressive
about something that hurts them a lot of
people will tell them they're being
aggressive instead of looking deeper mom
instead of looking deeper into what's
going on and seeing how that hurts them
and having empathy empathy is the
biggest thing I have but the thing is
you're not hearing me the root cause of
it is historical inaccuracy and lies
that you've been fed to say that the
nuclear family is white supremacy it's
an example of white supremacy here's the
thing do any of those ideas make black
children's lives better that makes it
worse makes it family does not make
really anybody's life better it's the
single biggest indicator that you have
success of ending up in prison of
graduating high school being literate or
having parents sure that's
useful inv in your life it's not even
close because of the nuclear family
right having your mom and dad right but
but what if an uncle takes that place
with a dad you can still have those
benefits right it's more so just only
having one parent to depend on it's not
because of the nuclear family it's
having one parent to depend on if
they're here's thing if one parent let's
say died right but they have had the
entire family come in and help those
children they're probably still as well
off right so why is that not happening
in the black black community it is it is
it is a black black is very we're Liv I
think it's a beautiful thing that you
are living but it's not statistically
it's not statistically there are more
there are more children in the black
community single household is not even
close and the family is not stepping in
and if you look at the tables you look
at the statistics regarding literacy
regarding graduate high school regarding
crime regardless how much class issue
because talking about like okay continue
yeah yeah it's the single biggest
indicator that we have of one success in
life from beh behavioral issues
successful relationships
themselves behavioral issues I'm walk I
I I'm telling you exactly what I think
it is I think it's very important for
children have parents in their Livy
because I plan on being a Psychology
major and I study this a lot a lot of
time um for medical issues and things
like that people will often diagnose
black children with behavioral issues
instead of looking at other criteria
prison H murder arson theft I'm not
talking about ADHD I'm talking about the
chances of single parent household this
is also a great murder prison theft
violent crimes right I'm just trying to
this is like a little pinpoint so I can
get you to see like a bigger picture I
suppose so when you look at like I
apologize for being myopic yeah so what
did you say I said I apologize for being
myopic yeah so um when we look at but
children right they're more likely to be
diagnosed with adhc and things like that
but also behavioral issues I'm not sure
what was that they tend to be I I just
uh with like different mental issues and
behavioral issues right let's go with
that so uh they're more likely to be
that with behavioral issues instead of
like other mental conditions right but
in reality they might fit those better
because of the perceived um racial
biases a lot of people have right and
this goes to like like medicine how
black women are treated and how they're
they're more likely to die in pregnancy
and child birth right uh and I feel like
that's just like a small Peck into how
like a greater Society treats a lot of
black people they ignore what we were
saying and they they choose to think
about us in a different from different
way than what actually is reality so can
I respond to that there are a couple of
things and this is where hopefully these
conversations can take place um there's
another reason that black women are more
likely to die during child birth and
that's because of
obesity and when we're talking about
behavioral disorders I'm not I'm talking
about I'm talking about murder talking
about violent crime 13% so if you ask
the why there so again is there a
certain point where is there a certain
point where it's not someone else's
fault I think everything's connected you
can't really take one thing away from
the if if we take that out though the
statistic you can't take it out's Go and
this is why I said not just behavi is
one of many that I listed right there's
no getting away from the 13% committing
52% of the violent crimes in this
country 13% of the population and it's
largely black men by the way so it's
really about under 6% so why is that why
is that and how why are usually white
men talking about statistics 133% of the
population 52% of the crimes which
doesn't help young black boys it's
you're not listening and this is not a
productive conversation so therefore the
conversation ends you're not to use my
data for anything
not we do not approve of being on camera
or doing anything a single party consent
State and you already did but I'm not
sure how productive the conversation is
anyway so not use I agree with that I
agree with that at all but it may be it
may be something that we use I'm asking
you not to use anything I will take it
into consideration and um I'll take it
into consideration okay we don't want
you to use anything with our face our
name on it whatsoever on anything having
to do with you your company so anything
for your YouTube video we do not consent
to it now are we going to disagree on
this we're single party consent laws are
you familiar with them or is that just
it's the law now if we want to have a
conversation about okay F where you
don't want to but you did consent to
this interview it started off as
friendly as all the others today and now
the law says but that doesn't matter the
law says it doesn't matter unfortunately
we do not consent great also what does
it say about you as a company to reeg on
our consent you know what I mean I feel
like as a company that's not great I
hate that it's called journalism was
right I hate that she was right it's
called journalism I hate that she and
your whole demeanor and everything about
you shifted but what I saying and and I
was so open for a beautiful conversation
and everything about you shifted I think
it shifted with the idea of
microaggressions and white fragility
because that's racist and that's my
opinion and you don't agree with it
that's fine and you'll say it's
privileged and you'll say that obesity
is because of of white people and you'll
say that the murder is because of white
mass murders but you abs everything I've
said is White Privilege everything is
white privileg must think about it as
like a company this is not great for
like if somebody straight up said we
didn't give you consent that's not why
why do you think you're the only ones
where that's the case also have a
question if your goal is to show this
love in this great of this community
this is is not productive right no I
should be shown I don't think that this
is good ambassadorship for them at all
so why are you fighting us I thought it
was going to be a deep great
conversation so why you f
why you want this to not be shown right
I feel like if your goal is to show
bonding and community and we're telling
you not to that goes against your
company ideals no well first off you
don't know the company or ideals but you
literally just said it's about bonding
community so why would you show us one
not wanting to that's not nice she's a
minor I am a minor but also like it's
just not a nice thing to do you know I
feel like from like a company
perspective you want like bonding
Community this is not what that's doing
no I I agree with you but I would ask
the question of yourself just like you
asked me to check privilege I would ask
of yourselves why is this the only one
where that's the case why are we out
here for hours well that's the thing is
there's the value in that is when you
talk about the company seeing the
contrast that some people don't have you
talked about the Bible ears to hear you
said that to me but I have never said
it's because you're black you can go
back through this and Rewind it I've
never once made a generalization that
because you are black you can't X or Y
you've both done it at least eight times
I said you're more like or you're more
and that's why I would say this one
wasn't she has I personally have not in
this entire thing I you're more supposed
to do St behaviors like most people are
because of society but I said because
you're white you're going to be doing
this thing I have not once said that and
I don't think because someone's white
they're more like they're going to do
one thing I think it's based on how they
all think I think it's everything we do
as humans is based on how we think you
know can we find can we find some common
ground on this if I'm going to take what
you're just saying and I and I believe
that it's 100% genuine can you listen to
what I'm about to say and just take it
into consideration so if you just said
that you've never once and your your
eyes I'm one thing one thing that I'm
about to say cuz everything I say you
say well no that's no believe what I'm
I'm taking you as genuine at your word
take me it's never going to be helpful
for you to start the conversation with
racial generalization like white
fragility so even if you make that in
other words remove that from your
vocabulary and maybe argue the art I
think it's a concept I think the word is
like a buzz word but the concept itself
is valid you know that people take in
what Society gives them and then they
have this way of thinking I think that's
a valid concept
I think I think it's the idea that you
are a byproduct of your environment sure
as a society people yes I would say
Society though because TV media let's go
with that then that's that's a big part
of it yes and that's what we started off
right let's go with TV media if they're
conditioned to think that then so let me
ask you this because I think this is
this is where we're making Headway what
you have expressed today would that be
more in line with everything that you
see in television and media than when I
am communicating the idea of white
fragility White Privilege that it needs
to be checked that systemically racist
that's what you'll see on CNN and ABC
and NBC and CBS right that would be I
think I think it's a lot more subtle
than that I think it's small things I
think you can say the big word out loud
and say white fragility is this XYZ you
can educate people but it doesn't undo
just only being exposed to certain
people right so a lot of people a lot
white people especially live in white
spaces they not really exposed to a lot
people color so that's how they're brain
thinks there's nothing necessarily like
it's not great right but it's not their
fault and I understand that just because
something is not their fault doesn't
mean it's not bad someone could be like
born with psycho psycho Psy what's it
psychopathy right that c that's a you're
born with most of the time sometimes
slightly raised right sometimes nature
nurture yeah that's fair right but that
doesn't mean it's a good thing right so
so something can be placed on you it's
not necessarily a good thing it's not
necessarily your fault either right but
it's something we should all work
narciss yeah but it's something we
should all work towards to bit better
from right like if I was born with
something horrible I have to work
towards and become a better person
through that same thing with something
was placed on me I have to work towards
let I become a better person that's with
literally everything so media in subtle
ways cuz it does happen subtly I mean
look at like this representation look at
on how on media and Disney Channel
especially Disney Channel uh how black
people and Asian people often are
portrayed little kids absorb that you
know and I feel like they have to do the
work now to get that out of their
minds so I think that's a fair State and
I think getting that out of your minds
people don't want to change and that's
that's where the right fragility comes
from it's not really because they're
fragile it's because they don't want to
change the way they think and they don't
want to go against the grain because
they don't want to admit to themselves
that they've been socialized in this way
and it's not their fault but they think
it's their fault because it's the way
they think yeah I think I think that
that is a it's the most unproductive way
of thinking of these issues that you can
imagine because there's no way to absorb
new information there's no way to use a
critical thinking lens because no matter
what I say you will say it's maybe it's
not white people's fault but it's
because they're white and if you go to
I think this happens with Asian people
as well you know I think yeah for
example affirmative action right they
were being screwed by uh that at Harvard
I wasn't talking about that I was
talking about Asians for sure you know I
don't think it's Asian for can you let
me continue my sentence I was talk
finished with my answer can I I was
sorry talking before you did your answer
um but what I was saying with Asian
people I was talking about sometimes
Asian people have this idea of black
fols because they're only the back looks
they're only shown a lot of the times
are these bad ser especially overseas
right and I feel like it's still bad but
it's not their fault so they had to work
through that right what it's because
they've been a victim of black violent
crime and disor overseas right now they
probably haven't statistically but in
the United States it's it's unbelievable
talking about overseas right now so can
I ask you a question so overseas like in
Asia so here's here I overseas yeah like
in Asia in Japan in Korea where there's
a where a monolith of races right ask
question so my the
undertones the undertones that I'm
feeling from you right now
are when is it when does black people of
color take responsibility why are black
women overweight why are men locked up
in prison these are the things that
you're amplifying right in in our
conversation because you're saying all
of these things no that's not what I'm
saying okay then that's how I that's how
you feel and at a certain point I what
I'm I'm not saying I don't care about
you I don't care how you feel about
those statistics that we were discussing
I wasn't one brought I wasn't brought on
second infant mortal infant mortality
rates and maternity death rates I think
that education is a great tool against
discrimination it's a great tool against
Prejudice and I think recognizing those
statistics and saying okay why do we now
I'm not saying that it's just because
black women are I'm not saying because
it's melanin but there are some other
issues that if you go wait maybe the
mortality rate for birthing mothers is
lower because of Health complications
comorbidities that's so that's a good
that's a clarification I don't disagree
but there's so much more than that
understand I understand but what I'm
saying is when you start
when I was addressing the issue that
it's solely based on race and I think
that if you look at it through that in
other words your daughter INR debate
said if you look at and rattled off
reasons for be well sorry I shouldn't
say for because women are black they XYZ
I'm think that's not because they're
black there are other there are other
compounding factors and I think that's
important so important is I think that
that's fair but I also think that the
Baseline it's not 100% because of any
color right I think the Baseline because
of History all of the things that have
compounded on each other leave us where
we are right now that's that's that's
the thing if we look about like red L I
think that I do think that choice is a
individual choice and responsibility is
the biggest component to that certainly
bigger than race I do that's my opin I
like from Psychology from psychology
perspective let me go from the heart let
me go from the heart real he's not going
to listen to that Mom he's only about
facts you know that right okay I know
that I know that you're about facts but
I want to go from the heart and and I
and I want you to hear me cuz we are I
know you think it's not going to work
but I if he chooses to a this without
our consent I I hopefully he airs this
part because I want to see the I want
you to understand I'm listening us being
where we are and my kids in Great
Schools and going off to college and
successful children in the two parent
household and all of that when we go
into the inner city and we do work we
volunteer and we volunteer and and I'm
listening to the other kids
one boy told me I didn't know and this
is education I didn't know that college
was an option I didn't know that smoking
weed is not what people don't that's
what we do every day because that's what
he sees that Mom that was her parent
mother and father before that parent was
that mother and father before so because
they're in this level of the same thing
in a school that's a title one school
that's not giving them the education
that the other schools are giving them
this becomes a cycle that they don't
even know how to get out of I didn't
come from that my grandfather is a
biologist my I'm third fourth generation
College I didn't come from that so
seeing that and understanding that even
as an affluent black woman seeing that
in that our um inner city kids don't
know know how to get out don't have the
Ed to get out and that is so powerful
and that's it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking that's the issue it's
education it's it's Ed exposure it's not
education because they go to school
every day right and they're they're not
being exposed education isn't working no
it's not it's not working because their
education is not the education that
she's getting so it's exposure someone
going into the inner cities and saying
your life can't be different let me show
you let me let me send you away to a
camp that says you're on a college
campus for this summer and this is what
this could potentially look like your
life does not have to be this it's it's
it's us really diving in and going in
and exposing our kids to different and I
and I think two things I agree with you
that's and that's why we're out here
it's incredibly heartbreaking and I
understand what you're discussing you
know coming from my father was raised in
Detroit the bad area of Detroit right he
was there when the first uh cross
District uh Bush uh busing integration
uh system and it it didn't go well they
had the Detroit Riots right he had
people had it worse were friends dads
who were black who were cops had to go
home and unmarked cars they were being
shot by other black men who were snipers
on rooftops it was a horrible war zone
he lived through it and I understand the
statistical reality and how unbelievably
hopeless it is for a lot of people by
the way in this and certainly black kids
in inner cities okay I agree with all of
those things now I would just make two
points and and allow you to just for a
moment consider that this isn't coming
from White prig but that this a space in
which I work and maybe I am well right
enough to to propose a solution that I
think we could all at least take a step
toward okay one is I think school is not
going we both agree school isn't fixing
it okay now we have to agree that it's
not because of money because these
schools get the same amount of money if
you look at it they do per pupil
spending is okay let's we're talking
about public schools public schools
that's unreal but let me can I can I
just finish please let me finish one one
trail of of of thought here let's assume
that I'm not lying about that okay let's
assume that P per pupil spending is
comparable
okay I think the most important thing is
going to be the kind of household that
you have created with a husband who you
love I think that's far more important
than school and here's how about this
how about the idea this is one solution
that I've always wondered why everyone
can't get on board with not school
choice and by that I mean a voucher I
don't mean defunding public education I
mean rather than forcing a child to go
to that school because that's his
district the voucher is attached to the
child and he can take it to any school
he wants I agree with that okay I've I I
agree with that 100% I agree with that
is like if they do you know do you know
why it's been shut down in the
government no because it's
racist the government's kind of I don't
govern we've been told that that is
racist for what you just said maybe some
black kids don't have parents with cars
maybe they it would be further for but
the point is right at least some choice
is better than no choice and I come from
can I agree with that 100 that that's a
policy that almost anybody could agree I
think the government itself has a lot of
issues I think anybody in America who
has a brain can see that the government
has issues and it's not serving the
people but is serving the people School
vouchers there there's Common Ground
yeah I agree and I've actively by the
way fought for that on a political level
you know the push back I face on that is
that's racist yeah from who well from
that's the push back on a national from
the Democratic National Committee that's
very interesting because and that's
because also that there's money tied
behind schools yeah there's funding so
all that comes that all that back down
to System of racism saying system that
doesn't work the system that doesn't
work my only disagreement there would be
it's not in other words I don't think
that schools in South Dallas with black
teachers with black principles I don't
think that they're racist I think that
there's no accountability in the public
school system has improved I don't think
agree with that I agree with that yeah I
also agree with that I'm just going to
say great we found cling ground I think
that the reason they're saying that it's
racist because it's obviously not right
I think it's because they probably have
some other like Financial reasoning
behind it that's prohibiting you and I
think that's the biggest issue in
America or not the biggest I think one
of the biggest issues in America today
is that our people up high are not doing
what they need to do to help the people
down blow you know what I mean I would
certainly agree that we have a problem
with uh government not representing
their constituency and not acting in the
best interest of the people completely
and I certainly would say that is true
of the public education system and I
think it's failed all children
particularly yeah children in the black
community it has not served them it's
not just children in the black
community it's children everywh Hispanic
it's black it's Asian if it's a white if
it's a little white kid that is at a
title one school he's still getting that
same across the board it's the
educational system problem that's across
the board yes but that I agree right but
the idea behind School choices so they
would say School vouchers and this is
why I say this because I think it's one
of those things where I've never heard
an argument against it that was valid is
sure maybe and I get this and we go back
to the idea of of a family right let's
say it's a black boy who doesn't have a
father who will drive him to another
school right he's going to be more more
disadvantaged than someone who does have
two parents but he is distinctly more
disadvantaged right now by being a
byproduct of what you said and I agree
with his immediate environment in other
words right now black where black
children are disproportionately
negatively affected is they have no
choice and so the school is a byproduct
of the environment and it is it's not
worked and so having the option to go
anywhere else and I say this because I'm
from Canada that's where I was raised
where I went to public school um I was
not raised in a wealthy household I was
raised in a three-bedroom apartment with
people about 900 ft uh but I did get a
much better education the reason I
didn't know until I moved to the states
as long as I was willing to get on a bus
I could go to a choice of five different
schools beautiful and uh I came to the
states and I go I said wait a second you
have to go to that school just because
it's your ZIP code people said yeah it's
archaic it's asinine and if there's no
other Common Ground I think that's
something that hopefully everyone can at
least move toward yeah I think that's
why like private school is gives you
such a bigger Advantage is because you
get to choose where you want to go and
teachers get fired if they're bad no
they do some do some don't some but more
than public schools that's true it
depends on the private school though cuz
there some private schools who will not
fire teachers who are like horrible
people um so because it's all it's money
if the teacher as a teacher has a parent
who's like really rich that endorses
them they don't get out so right
anywhere we go I think the school system
and we've kind of shifted gears here in
this conversation but no matter what the
school the school system is just that's
bad I think that black and white and
brown and Asian people should all be on
We this is one area we could all be on
the same page as far as reform for
public education should be a bipartisan
issue okay all right I wanted to leave
it on a because I genuinely do want to
hear and listen to you guys and I
understand a lot of your points disagree
with some but I'm glad that we found
something that we can genuinely uh agree
on because that has a real a material qu
uh material qu I'm getting heat stroke
quantifiable effect on people's lives I
was born here so I'm right yeah I was
not I was well we get 40 below so no one
fares too well in that either but yeah
this is uh this is rough uh Eddie and
carington caring Carrington Carrington
okay this is our future it's pretty good
it's all I can say I think there's
potential oh it's pretty good it's
better than potential she's off to
amazing college and going to do amazing
things I think that I'm glad that you
built a wonderful family and you're
supportive of your kids I think that's
very important and honestly across the
board people don't uh take it into
account enough regardless of race these
days and that's that's a beautiful thing
I mean that all right I apologize I
guess everyone's perfect and in no need
of improvement uh this wasn't entirely
fruitless still you can clearly see the
difference between this conversation and
all of the others that have taken place
uh in this series and i' point out
largely the difference seems to be that
people who haven't had to think
critically uh about their positions or
defend them if anything what was said
here could be modeled after every single
Legacy Media in white suburbanite talk
talking point that being said I respect
anyone willing to take the time to speak
and for that I thank you if you'd like
to see more of black and white and the
gray issues drop a like comment tell me
what topics you would like to see most
in the future installments remember none
of this is possible without you join the
fight and sign up for mug club today at
louder withcer docomo Club gain access
to an unrivaled catalog of unapologetic
and entertaining creators including the
Hodge twins Nick depal Brian K and of
course Alex Jones all that and
everything you see today is entirely
funded by viewers like you for $89
annually join the fight at lwith cr.com
mugclub
today